all right Morgan it sounds like we may
have a new Feud on our hands it's Black
Adam versus Shazam and it's not in the
comics it's in real life and in a
potential heel turn the villain could be
between Johnson fading so Carlos now a
new bombshell article from the rap
claims Dwayne tried to put himself at
the center of the DC extended universe
and personally put the kibosh on Zachary
Levi's Shazam character making an
appearance in a post-credits scene in
Black Adam yeah so this reportedly would
have seen Levi's character recruited for
the Justice Society until Johnson
personally vetoed the plan and instead
the post-critic sequence featured Black
Adam receiving a surprise visit from the
Man of Steel with Henry Cavill reprising
the role of Superman Dwayne allegedly
also nixed the idea of any Black Adam
superheroes appearing in a post-credits
scene in the Shazam sequel critics are
now questioning his decision as a
crossover could have helped both films
perform better at the box office Shazam
Fury of the Gods hit theaters on March
17th resulting in a disappointing
opening weekend with just 65 million
dollars at the worldwide box office a 43
percent drop from the first shazam movie
yeah now to add more fuel to the drama
Zachary seemingly confirmed this report
posting the article to his Instagram
story writing the truth shall set you
free to caught up with Zachary just a
few weeks ago in Toronto he seemed to
throw some shade a check out oh yeah did
you watch Black Adam I have not you
haven't I'm not are you gonna look are
you gonna watch it I eventually I mean
I've got a whole you know full plate of
other things that I need to get to in
life yeah and I know you are a comic
nerd and that you love it all what do
you think is happening with this DCU
world do you think what's going to
happen in the future and do you have any
ideas or I mean listen Peter Safran who
is my producer on Shazam I've known him
you know pretty well now for a few years
James Gunn I've known for many years
through mutual friends in Los Angeles
and I think that they're you know I
trust where they're going where they're
going to take this I think there were
you know very good hires
um I think that uh Peter has a lot of
excellent business sense and
diplomacy and uh and James is a
Visionary creative and and I really I
just I'm waiting to see what they have
in store because I'm excited about that
I'm feeling the shade he has a lot of
things he has to do in life in life like
that are on his plate in life in life
and just remind remembering I had to
remind myself when Black Adam actually
came out and that was October yes so
he's he's had some time and he's not
seen the movie which is just listen we
know what this game is like if you're
doing interviews and you're talking
about the DC extended Universe if you
are a part of that you're like ah even
if you don't like Black Adam even if you
don't like Dwayne Johnson you're like
yeah of course I've seen the movie and
you know and then you don't have to go
into details so the fact that he was
incredibly honest yes that's curious I
think about this from like the comic
fans perspective in the comments I love
this about you because like there's
always talk about like oh you're a
Marvel person or you're a DC person but
people that love it all really do love
it all and they want to see all their
favorite characters in great movies and
great story lines for years and years
right Marvel fans have gotten back
that's been a really nice thing for them
Disney fans though a lot of them will
say that a lot of the movies are great
and some of them love the Zack Snyder
stuff uh a lot of them haven't been as
good as they could have been a lot of
storylines haven't followed through as
well as they could have been followed
through in my opinion this is the way I
think about things and so when I think
about from a Comics perspective who
Shazam and Black Adam are like they are
from the same book like they came out at
the same time in that same book and they
are Arch enemies of each other so
storyline wise it does make sense that
they would come uh to a battle at some
point now that Henry Cavill uh
post-credits scene was the big thing
that everyone was talking about everyone
was talking about that but not because
of its attachment to that movie but
because of the idea that Henry Cavill
could be back as Superman and that's
what everybody wanted and then when it
turned out that he wasn't everyone felt
I think more disappointed that they were
excited for him to actually be in the
post credits I think that decision
definitely was a backfire and do you
think then that it's almost a bit
bizarre that until everyone got extreme
confirmation as to what was going on
Henry Cavill in the role that it just
was a bit strange now looking back that
he was in a post-credit scene of Black
Adam is it weird or no it's just you
would have also loved to have seen
Shazam in there I think the only way
that it makes sense is if you look at
the movies like they don't really matter
right like you you saw that scene and
there was a good time yeah it was great
but what those scenes are there for is
World building that's what that's how
we've established all uh mid and
post-credits themes always we're World
building so the expectation is this is
leading to something yeah right and if
we had had I think the original plan for
Shazam and I could be wrong someone will
correct me in the comments or whatever
you please feel free to I think the
original plan for Shazam was to have
Black Adam be the villain in Shazam
until until
um Dwayne and his team wanted pivot and
be like nah this character deserves a
full movie on his own okay and given
that like that would have made sense for
them you're in the same movie it yeah in
my mind yeah so it all seems a little
bit like
I don't know listen the whole state of
the DC EU before its new pivot to the
DCU under James Gunn and Peterson was
all up in the air anyways it's true this
whole time period was a bit of a mess
for fans and the hope is that moving
forward we will just have like a clear
straight line so fancy go Yep this is
what the storyline is this is what the
storylines are here are my favorite
characters doing awesome things like
that's kind of the whole movie yeah no
more no more drama
[Music]